tragedia brasileña aquí en el estadio de
la ciudad de la educación la sorpresa
sin duda alguna en esta copa mundo de
Qatar 2022 Croacia es la primera
semifinalista de este mundial después de
imponerse a la canariña en la tanda de
penaltis es la cuarta ocasión en dos
mundiales en la que el combinado europeo
logra superar esta instancia mientras
vemos cómo se hacen sentir los
aficionados croatas y empiezan a salir
del estadio celebrando esta Victoria con
la que prácticamente nadie contaba y
demás y después de un partido un
aficionado croata Que obviamente está
muy contento nadie contaba prácticamente
con esta Victoria por parte de los
croates pero fue un partido en el que
desde el comienzo el combinado dirigido
por Dales un monstruo que estaban aquí
para plantarle cara a Brasil No salieron
a esperar a la canariña la canarinha que
tuvo que recurrir la campiño para
intentar cambiarle la cara a este
encuentro la entrada de Anthony sin duda
alguna le dio un refresco a este equipo
que de la mano de tite quería conservar
esa idea de controlar el balón de jugar
de una manera ofensiva de generar esas
jugadas cooperativas el partido al
término de los 90 minutos terminó
igualado a cero con dos mano a mano que
falló Neymar otro que falló Lucas
paqueta y con también el casi que un gol
brillante que termina después por parte
de brozovich que después de una
asistencia excepcional por parte de
petcovich uno de los refrescos de este
combinado croata para la prórroga
parecía que finalmente la suerte sonreía
para Brasil con un golazo por parte de
Neymar al comienzo de los primeros 15
minutos adicionales Neymar que conseguía
así igualará Pelé como el máximo
anotador por parte de la canalería en 77
goles pero Brasil entregó la pelota en
esa segunda parte de la prórroga y fue
ahí donde llegó de nuevo petcovich esta
figura que ha salido del banquillo para
llevar el partido a los penaltis y ahí
iba a surgir otra de las figuras de
desencuentro de nuevo domenic libakovic
el portero de los croatas natajó el
primer penalti de Rodrigo que finalmente
iba a ser uno de los verdugos de este
encuentro el otro Verdugo para los
brasileños fue marquiños que con su
último disparo que vio en el poste le
dio el pase a los croatas Neymar que
tuvo un partido tanto se quedó
finalmente sin cobrar porque estaba
previsto que lanzara el quinto encuentro
partidazo también de Luka modric que fue
Quien comenzó ese gol del empate para
los croatas que ahora esperan rival
entre Argentina o Países Bajos